you're done okay i'm in you know you
have to leave
what's up everyone it's warren and that
is what i feel tom holland
just did to us tonight after teasing us
with a fake
title reveal today then jacob battle on
getting on board and then
zendaya getting on board all revealing
fake titles before
tom holland went on the jimmy fallon
show making us believe that they were
going to reveal the title of spider-man
3 on the show they even played a whole
segment on the show with tom holland
called
instant spoilers with tom holland and
in the game they guessed titles based
off of things they said it was literally
spoiling the titles of movies and they
still
didn't reveal the title it's kind of a
big screw you to the fan base if i'm
being perfectly honest but they did play
us
i don't know if this is a stunt to drive
views to jimmy fallon or if they're just
having some fun
zero idea but we didn't get the title
and i apologize for that
but they trolled us very very hard
hopefully we get it soon they were
teasing it so maybe it's coming soon but
at this point in time
i don't really know i'm surprised they
did all that teased
fake titles and then played a literal
game called instant spoilers with tom
hollands about titles and they still
didn't give it to us
so if i hear anything else of course
i'll let you know and do an update video
about that but in the meantime express
your frustration in the comments down
below about how
hard we got trolled tonight be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on anything
we possibly find out about spider-man 3
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
you